[Music]
I hope that all of you really think
about what it is that you want to leave
we all have material things we all have
things that we own that we like we you
know
treat ourselves and all that stuff but
what you leave should be bigger than you
see you guys soon
you
we have a few questions for you Disney
Channel we want to know how you manage
to create awesome TV shows and play
matchmaker at the same time your actors
are constantly falling in love on set so
we're convinced that you have a secret
love radar or something your knack for
creating the most picture-perfect
couples is beyond impressive and we
can't wait to see which famous couple is
formed next Disney Channel stars are
falling in love left right and center
these amazing couples are totally
changing the game you won't believe how
many couples fell for each other while
on set keep watching to find out which
unlikely duo turned out to be a match
made in heaven
Bella Thorne and Gregg Sulkin Bella and
Gregg have both had successful Disney
Channel careers and they famously moved
on with their lives and became big stars
but unfortunately their Disney days
aren't the only thing they chose to
leave in the past Gregg played the role
of Mason gray back on Wizards of Waverly
Place for two full years back in 2010
and it's here that you met his future on
and off again girlfriends Bella Thorne
Bella only appeared in one single
episode but evidently it was enough to
capture Greg's attention despite no
longer dating Bella and Greg have
continued their friendship proving that
we can be friends without our exes Doug
Cameron and Ryan McCarten once upon a
time Devin Ryan wrote one of the best
couples in Disney history they met on
the set of Liv and Maddie and sparks
instantly flew fans watched as Maddie
and diggie fell in love on the small
screen and soon found out that it wasn't
all an act
Devin Ryan eventually got engaged but
their romantic story came to an abrupt
halt in 2016 when the Disney stars
decided to call it quits
Kate Meyer and Rowan Blanchard Peyton
and Rowan's relationship might have been
short and sweet but it happened and fans
remember it like it was yesterday back
in 2015 Peyton and Rowan met on the set
of Girl Meets World and instantly felt a
connection I choose you
Peyton played the role of Lucas friar
while
Rowan starred as Riley Matthews just
fight their fans rooting for them Payton
and Rowan broke up in early 2016
their Girl Meets World love story will
go down in Disney history
Cameron voice and Peyton lists Cameron
voice is a total sweetheart and arguably
the cutest VK in descendants history he
first crossed paths with Peyton lists
while in the set of Jesse
oddly enough Cameron Peyton were cast as
brother and sister but that didn't stop
them from crushing on each other a while
on set the adorable couple dated for a
total of three years before parting ways
in 2015 there were also rumors that
Cameron was dating co-stars Brenna
D'Amico dove Cameron and Sofia Carson
but in truth they were all just that
rumors so far the only Disney
relationship Cameron has been involved
in was with ex-girlfriends Peyton lists
Jake short and china anne mcclain china
anne mcclain is a super talented Disney
Channel star who's well known for
playing uma in The Descendants franchise
but before she was cast as Ursula's
daughter she played Chyna parks in ant
farm and it's here that she met her
ex-boyfriend Jake sort who played the
role of Fletcher Quimby Chyna and Jake's
relationship was short and sweet but
fans have yet to forget about it they
dated from 2012 to 2013 before deciding
to continue on as friends Cole Sprouse
and Victoria Justice Cole Sprouse might
be dating his current Riverdale co-star
Lilly Reinhardt
but the two weren't always an item
before meeting Lily Cole dated a handful
of people who also happened to be his
co-stars Cole met and briefly dated
sweet life actress Catelyn Pippi back in
2009 and he also casually dated Sophie
Oda and Victoria justice during his time
on the show he met all three of his
ex-girlfriend's while filming for the
hit Disney series suite life of zack &
cody Zac Efron and Vanessa Hudgens
if there's one Disney couple who will
never be forgotten it's this one right
here they're beyond iconic and that's
probably because their relationship
lasted longer than any other Disney
relationship Zach and Vanessa met on the
set of High School Musical and the rest
is pretty much history they
dated from 2006 to 2010 and are still on
friendly terms today Nick Jonas Selena
Gomez and Miley Cyrus Nick Jonas has
been breaking hearts and taking names
since he first entered the Disney
Channel world today he's married to
Priyanka Chopra but before finding his
OTP he dated a few of his Disney
co-stars Nick dated Miley Cyrus for
about two years in 2006 and he also
dated Selena Gomez for several months in
2008 Joe Jonas AJ and Demi Lovato just
like his brother Nick Joe Jonas has
dated more than one of his Disney
Channel co-stars today he's happily
married to Game of Thrones star sophie
Turner but once upon a time he used to
date Demi Lovato Demi and Joe met on the
set of camp rock in 2007 and briefly
dated back in 2010
Joe also dated Disney star AJ Michelle
qey in 2006 when their band's Jonas
Brothers and Aly & AJ went on tour
together dubbed Cameron and Thomas
Doherty we saved Devin's hummus for last
because they're one of the few Disney
Channel couples that are still going
strong they've been dating ever since
they met on the set of descendants two
and they are total couple goals Duff has
found love on the Disney Channel on more
than one occasion but this time she's
older and wiser and totally in it for
the long haul
their on-screen chemistry in d2 was
palpable to say the very least which one
of these Disney couples is your OTP
sound off in the comments section thanks
for watching the things for more videos
about your favorite Disney Channel stars
hit that subscribe button and don't
forget to give this video a big thumbs
up see you next time
[Music]